nous sommes à bagneux dans les
hauts-de-seine la ville compte plus de
60 9 % de logement social et c'est
beaucoup pour le gouvernement qui veut
prendre la main sur la construction de
ces habitations à loyer modéré la
décision d'accorder ou non un permis de
construire appartient jusqu'à présent
aux maires des villes concernées mais ça
pourrait en être autrement à l'avenir
l'objectif est de n'autoriser la
délivrance de ces agréments que dans des
cas très limités en vue d'assurer la
cohérence de l'action de l'état au titre
de renouvellement urbain de la
requalification des îlots dégradés de
l'aménagement des quartiers proches de
grandes infrastructures de transport ou
de la mise en oeuvre du plan égalité des
chances partie intégrante de l'ensemble
des mesures décidées lors du comité
interministériel des villes cette mesure
doit contribuer à améliorer les
conditions de vie de nos concitoyens et
à lutter contre le sentiment de
relégation une proposition de loi des
sénateurs is dominique estrosi et
valérie létard qui doit être discutée
début décembre à l'assemblée nationale
va dans ce sens qu'elle vise à donner au
gouvernement la décision pour la
production de logements sociaux dans les
communes qui en compte plus de 40 % et
faut dire qu'il y en a beaucoup 43
villes sont concernées en ile-de-france
et dans l'oise
le taux de logement social atteint 69% à
dugny 61% à l'île saint denis ou encore
56% à trappes et à bonneuil-sur-marne l
ile de france regroupe un million trois
cent mille logements locatifs sociaux s
est un quart du parc national et
pourtant l'offre est très loin de
répondre aux besoins en 2019 dans la
région sept cent trente six mille
demandes étaient enregistrées pour
seulement 72 mille attributions dans
l'oise où nous enregistrons 5000
demandes en attente
si nous construisons plus où est ce que
les gens vont habiter on marche sur la
tête il y à 700 mille demandes de
logements sociaux rien quand il dort la
construction de hlm est en chute libre
depuis que macro et président et voilà
que maintenant ils veulent s'attaquer au
maire qui en font trop malgré la forte
demande ce que souhaite l'une des deux
sénatrices à l'origine de la proposition
de loi c'est d'éviter je cite de créer
des ghettos on ne dit pas qu'il ne faut
plus construire ce type de logement mais
évitons d'en faire là où il y en a déjà
une forte concentration au risque de
créer des ghettos il ne faut pas
rajouter de la pauvreté à la pauvreté
d'accord mais cela ne règle pas le
problème de ceux qui attendent un
logement social certains depuis dix ans
et puis chili à certaines villes dites
riches au faible taux de logement social
qui refuse d'en construire davantage une
centaine d'élus de gauche d'île de
france ont annoncé leur intention de
manifester le 10 novembre devant le
ministère du logement pour dénoncer la
situation je cite catastrophique du
logement en france il souhaite placer ce
qu'ils appellent une urgence absolue au
centre du débat de la campagne
présidentielle